the reality of real estate market
article written by tom zenner go to
vtpost.com to
read other articles and by the way we
have a a
vt uh uh post insider for
dollar a month you pay for the first 90
days and it goes to 3.99 you get insider
stories that we do and a couple unique
products that we're sending your way but
the reality of real estate market there
are 1.39
licensed realtors for every house sold
in the us pretty crazy when you think
about this
go a little lower to show the data here
go a little lower when you look at this
data here
so uh what was it the more licensed real
estate agents than
total number of houses for sale
nationally think about that more real
estate licensed
agents than total number of houses for
sale
nationally coupled with the record low
interest rates and the strongest housing
boom in 15 years and it becomes
understandable
how this could happen here's the data
all the way at the bottom if you look at
it all the way at the bottom
it's an unusual euro and real estate
sector the economy so strange in fact
that 1.5 million
members were listed in the national
association of realtors
while there were only 1 million 40 000
homes for sale across the united states
a 26
decrease from the previous year insane
it is a seller's market
sell if you can if you're thinking about
selling this your next year
sell this year okay i may be wrong this
is just an opinion i am not a real
estate expert
but i'm telling you if you're thinking
about selling in the next couple years
so this is a great point i'll back it up
with some data um 36
of the houses sold last month nationally
sold above
asking price 36 nationally
the sellers got more than they were
asking and here's the other thing every
single market has gone up except one
san francisco down people are bailing on
san francisco it's the only major market
where the cops pelosi is probably
so pissed off right now why would you
guys leave uh san francisco and
disappoint nancy pelosi heartbreaking do
you have thoughts on this are you good
to go you want to go to trump again
at the end of the day i think it's going
to whether just in any business
specifically real estate it's going to
be the 80 20 rule
the top 20 of the realtors are going to
do 80 of the business and the the other
are gonna fight for the scraps of the 20
that's just the same in any sales
business you know
same in uh someone else's company that
you're rocking today i assume
80 20 rule this is my philosophy right
there so there's a million
freaking realtors by the way honestly
you're on fire today no joke
water on me today so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you